Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Six: the players in a democracy, and democracy in everyday life.
There are many participants in a democracy.
The voters are the foundation of the system.
They are the ones who supply the politicians with power.
In daily political life, the politicians and the parties play a central role when new legislation is to be passed.
But there are many others who try to get influence on democratic decisions.
Interest organisations and associations try to influence political life.
The media also mean a lot for which questions get onto the political agenda.
In addition, private business and the public sector also play a role.
Let's meet them one by one.
And here are the Danish names again.
Socialdemokratiet, Venstre, Radikale Venstre, Det Konservative Folkeparti, SF, Moderaterne, Liberal Alliance, Dansk Folkeparti, Enhedslisten, Alternativet, Danmarksdemokraterne and Borgernes Parti.
First, the voters.
It is the basic principle of democracy that all power comes from the people, that is, the voters.
And there is a hard fight for the voters' favour.
Fewer and fewer voters vote for the same party all their lives.
Sixty years ago, most voters voted for a party that matched their work and their class in society, and that looked after their economic interests in particular.
Workers typically voted for the Social Democrats, farmers voted for Venstre, and the self-employed and the middle class typically voted for the Conservative People's Party.
Voters were loyal to their party and to the party's ideology.
They often voted for the same party every single time, almost regardless of how the party acted in the political system.
That is no longer the case.
Voters change party far more often today.
Voters also vote more on the basis of their views on questions that do not necessarily have to do with their own economic interests.
That can be views on individual issues that are politically topical right now.
These can concern health, immigration, climate, how hard crime should be punished, or something completely different.
On the other hand, there are still patterns in voting.
Privately employed people vote more for centre-right parties.
Publicly employed people vote more for the Social Democrats and other parties on the left wing.
Men vote more for centre-right parties, and women more often for parties on the left wing.
Venstre and the Denmark Democrats are often strong in the rural areas, while SF, the Red-Green Alliance, the Social Liberal Party and the Alternative have most of their voters in Copenhagen and other of the biggest cities.
Second, the political parties.
The political parties are probably the most important participants in Danish democracy.
At elections, the political fight takes place between the parties.
In the choice between different political parties, voters can express their political views.
The parties act in that way as mouthpieces for the population's different political opinions, but they also have great influence on voters' opinions.
When parties announce certain political views, it influences the voters.
In the daily political work too, the parties play a crucial role in the ongoing political debate.
The political parties are not mentioned in the constitution.
When Denmark got its first constitution in 1849, there were no political parties as we know them today.
A member of the Rigsdag was to serve the whole people and not be bound by special interests.
But gradually, as democracy developed in the second half of the 1800s and the beginning of the 1900s, political interest groups and parties arose.
As a citizen, you can be a member of one of the political parties.
Around 1950, about 650,000 people were members of a political party.
That corresponded to almost one in four of those with the right to vote in general elections.
Since then, the number has fallen considerably.
In 2024, the number was about 106,000.
That corresponds to about one in forty of those with the right to vote in general elections.
The biggest party, the Social Democrats, has about 27,000 members, and the second biggest, Venstre, about 20,000.
It is the parties' members who decide whom a party should nominate as candidates, and thereby which candidates the rest of the population can vote for at an election.
Even though the political parties have fewer members, they are still very important participants in democratic life, and they also have great influence on voters' opinions.
Third, the members of the Folketing.
A member of the Folketing is bound only by their personal conviction, and not by any instruction from the voters or from their parties.
This is what the Danish constitution says.
It means that the member in principle only represents themself.
They can therefore vote against their party's official policy, for example if it conflicts with their personal views.
As a main rule, however, individual politicians follow their party's political line.
In some cases, a party in the Folketing decides that its members are set free.
In those cases, the party does not set a common position.
Most often this happens in cases about morals and ethics.
That could for example be in discussions about abortion, artificial insemination or the rights of homosexuals.
A member of the Folketing can also choose to leave their party if they no longer feel in agreement with the party's views.
In that case, the person can become either a loner, a løsgænger, or a member of another party.
But they keep their membership of the Folketing until the next general election and can continue to take part in votes.
The Speaker of the Folketing, Folketingets formand, is Søren Gade from Venstre.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which party did farmers typically vote for in the middle of the 1900s?
Option A: The Danish People's Party.
Option B: The Greens.
Option C: Venstre.
[DA] Hvilket parti stemte landmænd typisk på i midten af 1900-tallet?  A: Dansk Folkeparti  |  B: De grønne  |  C: Venstre
The answer is C: Venstre.
It appeared in the June 2020 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Venstre
Question 2.
Which party did workers typically vote for in the middle of the 1900s?
Option A: Venstre.
Option B: The Social Democrats, Socialdemokratiet.
Option C: The Social Liberal Party.
[DA] Hvilket parti stemte arbejdere typisk på i midten af 1900-tallet?  A: Venstre  |  B: Socialdemokratiet  |  C: Radikale Venstre
The answer is B: The Social Democrats, Socialdemokratiet.
It appeared in the November 2020 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Socialdemokratiet
Question 3.
How have the political parties' membership numbers developed overall since 1950?
Option A: They have fallen.
Option B: They have risen.
[DA] Hvordan har de politiske partiers medlemstal overordnet udviklet sig siden 1950?  A: De er faldet  |  B: De er steget
The answer is A: They have fallen.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in June 2026.
[DA] ✔ A: De er faldet
That's the end of Part One of Episode 6.
In Part Two, we continue with interest organisations, the media, and democracy in everyday life.
See you there.